[Laughter]
[Music]
Hey guys Oh mubebi I want to talk
e-book butterfly is calling Noah, we want
this and this, Chasing Dreams by a
help type love is also used here
maybe smiling Indonesian
has a body talking Lazy ah ah
nickel  Bitter sweet nickel ore
Indonesian crafts okay yes yes yes
in Indonesia Indonesia
Indonesia Indonesia Indonesia trail
ends all uh no
Hey respect the teacher the milk indicator is
typing just talking by the way
want to want to want to see the ring
prefer impossible
Hi tayo Indonesia but why not  can
say impolite dancing naked and
lying uh uh uh happy also lit up
normal
smiling face cream hehehe hehehe
[Music]
hehehe
[Applause]
itunesamazonmp3
[Music]
Hey I hope the villages of
Garut are stupid
[Music]
[  Applause]
hi hi
Rp
Hi hehehe hehehe hihihi hihihi
hihihi so want to say i
Hey it's raining you are covered  s longser by
just kopikopo tap to pause
pause oh my god culture including ume
join join this song fits
[Music]
Hey nuclides enter the
presentation we want to sell it's important
you are stupid Kowe happy happy
Serena
habibi.com Hi beautiful Music chirping Ouch water pop
confused already oh no
hi hi
the lounge